foreign
[Music]
seems normal
people who left after the invasion of
Ukraine have started to return the city
has reopened people go about their daily
lives
but the war is never far
e Raid Sirens every few hours constant
reminders of living close to the Russian
border
rawad is from Fallujah he fled Iraq
after the American Invasion only to find
himself in the middle of a Russian one
I want to stay here in Sumi I don't want
to leave this country I have to consider
it because of my wife and child but if I
listen to my heart I don't want to go
this place gave me more than my own
country if you would ask me to choose
Iraq or Ukraine I would definitely
choose Ukraine
robot came as a medical student learned
the language became a doctor and a
Ukrainian citizen
he started several small businesses
bringing a bit of the Arab world to
Ukraine he's lived here for 17 years met
his wife who is also Iraqi and had a
child he reluctantly sent them back to
Iraq
across Ukraine lives have been in limbo
ever since the war broke out before the
invasion this city was a favorite for
people who were looking for an
affordable place to live and attend
University International students from
Asia Africa and the Middle East numbered
in the few thousand now only a few dozen
as recently as July a Russian rocket
attack killed two people when it hit
this Vocational School
incidents like this are still driving
people out of the city
Dasha manages several downtown cafes she
says half her staff before the war were
men who went to fight
when the war started we had a difficult
time because no one knew what to do next
we just warned all our employees to
leave the country as soon as possible
even as small businesses in towns like
Sumi begin to recover
drones and Rocket attacks make for
sleepless nights
despite hazards and uncertainty rawad
says his family wants to come back
[Music]
to live in their adopted home
or die trying
Sumi in Northern Ukraine